ok
yesterday con
construction is going to
General Every Time We replicate this
entire
structure ok so these are these are
channels there is some some
eo
replic and there are hales bott hal
Ander Half the bottom Half is Connected
by these wires To The upper Half so this
Goes On and On the algebraic description
of What we are doing Here
is
u
x can be described
As R vectors X1 X2 mulp by this Matri
Call it
F Us
u12 we go to the size
construction the size
construction transformation is you Take
the F Matrix
and you  Simply do This is the chronic
second chronic Power of F so the second
transformation the one that you see Here
this This
Part
transformation
is Vector Here and mulp by
Matri that
gives
length Here We are seeing the length
encoding
operation vect
of
V also length That's Given  by this
transformation
chronic x the exponent here is the
length of the Vector so in General in
Other Words for any length n Which is a
Power of
2 We have a cod and the cod is Given
by doing this m
later of but a little later i  will Show
by example that this operation can be
Done
in order and
Logan
steps There is no big Factor Here in
fact you could Just Say n Times Logan
arithmetic Operations are needed in
order to do the encoding This is very
similar to F transform in the F
transform We
have Operations Over The real number
Field and We have a Basic
Butterfly This is the Butterfly uh in
the Case of the polar transform it's
Over the binary Field ffds over complex
or Real Field complex Field More pris
All the algebraic properties shortcuts
implementation tricks that  are Valid for
fft and There is a huge literature about
that they are val also in this
context perhaps More so because there
are no multiplications Here it's only
additions ok
[Music]
so demonstrated already
that this type of transformation is
going to achieve polarization As We  Keep
increasing the construction
size so We Were Here
yesterday There is a martingale in Here
embedded in this in this
construction Which helps
Us Say very prise Things about
Here
remembering w
Channel binary input discrete Mem
channels Call w We Take two independent
copies of it and  then We generate a w
wus and
w
Y2
and the w min
Channel a Channel Whose input is X1 + X2
this We Call
u1 the output is y1 and
Y2 w chel binary input Channel Whose
input is X2 or U2 and the output is y1
Y2 and
u1  so these channels are i have
already Dra this picture so let me Just
Show it
Here This is Channel w This is Channel w
Here We have y1 Here We have
Y2 w min
Channel this
One this One regarding this treating
This As
noise so We May Just  include it inside
the box This is the w minus
Channel this one is treated As Complete
noise one one Half One inability
and After You decode Do your decoding on
w minus you Gain Access to the w Plus
Channel and the w Plus Channel
Has input
U2 u  is Now provided After it's decoded
it's provided As an output to the second
Channel This is a little fictitious
because Nobody will provide this
of
this available but As We Said
Last polarization Us Since we will use s
this over Channel Whose Capacity is near
one probability of  making
decis so
We That's
Idea Let's Look at the polarization the
martingale This martingale
is out
of
conservation so i
have
Capacity of
w Plus Capacity of w
Plus equ
i Capacity Here equ to the Origin
Original
Capacity they are the w
This is the
cap i two  different
not iw This is the
symmetric
Capacity This is assuming that q of at
the
input q
of this is
of this the ru
ok i made the assumption that the
Channel
is symmetric so that We always have
through this presentation We always have
this if w is
already symmetric in the in a
Sense input output symmetric sometimes
called if it Has some degree of symmetry
this
Way ok so The
maro A tool foral This
is Where
is
area population
of
process ok so what We Want to What we
want to do is We Want  to
understand a little bit We Want to
understand the fraction of channels
Which are Extreme channels either have
cap near One or near
Zer We are interested in the fraction ok
so the
distribution of the of the capa it is a
probability distribution when you do the
normalization  We are really interested
in understanding the probability
distribution relating to the capacities
of these
channels so Which fraction lies for
example between 0 and
0.1 this can be
One at Random What isil that the
Capacity is than a certain
number if i
can
if picking
unp
i would  be able to That's the equ in
Other Words That's What interested in
learning
so The Reason We Want to
putu
w so they have cap equ to with
probability One are at this Point One in
this example This is an example in which
C
one now What i
do if the size of the construction is
going
to
w and w
Plus
of Random
ok There is a Random
process
cho
Random
up
current
Can
ind
Ed
value Time
one of my mutual information Channel
Capacity is probability hal Go Up
and
ok
average precisely Same
as equ  i of w of
w by this equation by the fact Mut
information is con here i
to i want to Look at this As
w R process at Time Zer to constructing
sequence
of sequence like this Where i Start at w
and then randomly Go Up and
Down  and w2 for example corresponds to a
Random choice at this
level ok so w1 is either this One or
[Music]
wabil this and so so i generate a
Uniform
distribution i
generate a Channel process if you
like Random
process Random process Where the value
of
the  Random variable at each Random
object at each Time instant is a Channel
ok so This is
the ok We define
this process for channels and the
numerical values ​​Associated with the
channels namely the mutual information
terms or Capacity terms they constitute
a
martingale so This is the first  step of
the Mar why is it the Mar the
expected
The Next
Step equal to the present value but
Let's write the Next one to
because We need to martingale when we
speak about the martingale We need to
speak about Another process Mar relative
to Something
else
is  ber
process
ber
state are the Dire selectors B1 is
determining Go up or Down
Here
maring
foll
expectation of the
value at Time n+
One
Given knowledge
of the first End
steps this
condition Given knowledge of this i know
where i am in this at Time n because
being told whether i went up or Down at
Time One at Time
ETC so this
One This is equal
to i of
w
n i of w
n so for example Do a very small example
Say B1 equ to B1 0 and B2
1 and Let's suppose that one means We  Go
Up and Zer means We Go
Down Let's calculate the
expectation Let calculate the
expectation
will Time CC expectation of Capacity i
w3 Given that
B1 and
B2 We can do it using
this
w so i
took step Down w w
w B1 equ
z0 and
w1
w and The  Next Step
Up and
ST Channel State is w2
w2 w
Plus so Now Going toing at What doing
here
w3
w w w
Plus
w
basu
that have
this Basic
construction conservation
Law the of the cap of these two channels
Since they are originating from a common
anc  this
equ i of w minus Plus
writing the same equation All the Time
regardless of the This depth is the
entropy
conservation but This is precisely
What
martingale being a martingale means ok
so That's it
uh ok so
i so the Mar language is helpful in
describing the  process but
in
Here ok so essentially Says this This
theorem Here it Just Falls out of
Standard martingale facts What
does What kind of Mar do We have
here so process the
process i
of Let's Now write a different process a
numerical process uh the Other Day with
David and i We Were discussing whether
uh things that Don't Take Real values
can be called Random variables so here i
talked about the Random
process i Call the w process a Random
process
and w is not Real number
Channel We canot
about so We Want  to Talk
about Real valu
process so we will use this notation i1
i2
ETC ok so or More concisely it T Great
equ
Zer This is martingale
relative
to the same process that We have written
b t Great or equ To 1
Here What is it it is defined
As at Time T wt is this Channel sequence
it is not a Random process but this one
is because it's Real value it
's this process Here
it OK the process
it is
bounded
B so İt lies in
bed All
the values ​​are in the interval Zer to
one
bounded Mares
converge bed Mares
converge
randi Rand
variable
will
con
Other limit Random variable Here in Our
example i Sub İnfinity so There is such
a Random variable It's a proper Random
variable it has a distribution the
distribution of this
limit polarization
this
Can takes Z
and but  There is L1 convergence Which
enables Us To Say That the expectation
of
it converges to the expectation of i
İnfinity This is L1
convergence if the Mar is not a bounded
Mar This is not True always so you have
to have
the fact that it is bonded helps  Us also
Make this
statement What this
One ok so the expectation of i İnfinity
After you show That it Can only Take the
valu Z z0 or
One We have in fact
expectation of
w of w because
İSU
tak
of
w
Yes so what you Used in  this is that You
Had Some Kind of conservation la Right
so so any transformation that sort of
Has this conservation Law not
necessarily Be The one that you have
The One X1 and X1 Plus X2 would Still
work Right i me all this missionary
would go through  i mean you need bounded
But but if a binary input then it is
Bound so as long
as you create channels from the current
no ok in such a Way That uh you
conserve
Capacity so what Goes Wrong if gu use
the identity mapping Well with the Okay
That's good question i will answer Your
question Okay it's Thank you for asking
the
question i will clarify that Point Let
Me
for because We Mar and conservation
this for finite Right we
begin you show it by
induction so because We have
Mar if i stop at
Time  My Fortune expected
Fortune i do it
Wrong My expected Fortune at Time T if i
stop There is the same As My initial
Fortune because it is a it is a Mar
fine ok Now i also know The Following i
of
T using two different notations Now let
me the notation
so This is my initial Fortune meed
in bits Chanel cap and This is my
Fortune at time also measured in bits
Channel Capacity so it is
conc What else do i know i know that
this converges almost surely to a limit
Random
variable This is  whether it's bounded or
not As Long As have a
Mar
Maran
inte SL Technic but This is
very but this not
strong strong for by
at
İnfinity This is because bounded
Mar Bound is a sufficient condition for
this to be so also able to say this ok
so  these two facts are General Mar the
they have nothing to do with the details
of this
construction not using any of it you
know As Long As Mar b
ok i Said Something
else that i
İnfinity i İnfinity ok so Let's first
put these two facts
Together expectation  of it is equ to
ier expectation of it is not Moving
around it is just staying at ier
ok limit
is the expectation of
İnfinity
i this limit Random variable i don't
know what distribution but expectation
equ to Original Channel Capacity i of
w
Now How  do i know that this thing is
polarized That it is either Z or one
valu now Here you Said What if i Take F
by combining Matrix As the identity
Matrix in Words You are not doing
anything so this will not
polar This is not going to polar  so what
do i need We need to do addal work ok
for that these are going to be but
w limit Random
Here equ to i of w Nothing is Moving
around There is no
polarization
ok
have
inequity create Two
channels one of them
is one of them  is better than The
Original Channel and the Other is worse
than The Original
Channel is the condition for equality
Here if equity One
on
if the Channel Here is Extreme
Channel if and Only if iw equ Zer or
One This
is bergers
lem That's sufficient to prove
this  but it can be proven otherwise in
fact i did it using the but char
distance so the Z parameter for a
Channel but it can be Done it can be
Done in many Ways
ok and
you ian any can do this in 10
minutes so if i can  't do 10 minutes that
means to
Listen ok
ok Maybe i can do
it but This is this is Something i want i
want i want to skip over ok so
normally you have this so unless you
with extreme Channel in
this to Split Apart you have  w Here or wt
Let's Say We have a Channel wt at
Time T and then We Look at the children
ok so the
children's Mut
information cap are going to
be
Going sep each
other and
further One Can Put a lower the amount
of separation in term of  the
distance Z
or ok if a
Channel
w
del
minimum w
and 1 min i of
w this
Delta is a function Which is strict
positive ok if is posi you see What i
mean ok There is a result like
this it is similar to the entropy power
inequality That's also an inequality of
the same sort This is for the
are manys
do the
is is rigorous proof of this One but
intui answer İs The
Following We know
that There is this limit i w
İnfinity
equum for
process More You Get splitting ok so How
can you have this As the limit because
the process from any Point onwards it
Has Children Which keeps Moving Apart so
the only Way You Can have the limit in
Other
Tool
statement it has to
be possible limit points of this process
are Zer and One ok We  can Make this More
precise Than i'm saying
now now having After you do that then
you have The Following
Everything then There is nothing left so
You
also OK so by that
argument ok because There is
separation exation each step limit has
to and probability
that  the number of channels the fraction
of channels Which are converting to
Perfect
Channel this number Right probability of
i İnfinity being
equ
Because of i
İnfinity Which equ i of
w ok have exact the same fraction As The
Original
Capacity To The To The upper limit it is
not surprising Of
course There is one Fur Thing Which i
May Say Here in order to Give
in
con
in Here İs The
Following This is Zer This is one
and the process starts here and there
are all kinds of PS as you
see let consider you know  a point Which
is Close To One After a number of
steps so It's a like
this
the offspring of this do you see As You
Close To the boundary it becomes
extremely difficult to move Away from
the boundary because you cannot for a
Children a child cannot do  this ok
because the Other child would have to do
that in İn that Case it would have to
become larger than one because There is
entropy conservation the mean has to be
Here so As You Close To the boundary the
step
have to become smaller and
smaller so  it is like the time slowing
Down you Keep spending The Rest of your
life most of them near the boundaries so
the boundaries are absorbing boundaries
in some Sense You never Hit the boundary
but Once You Get Close To it you cannot
move out of the boundary like  a Black
hole and Strong
gravitation
of it
Escape so there will be a certain
fraction Which will Escape they will
come Back Down and Maybe move in the
middle ok so That's Why The
processes not so
Simple and to a certain extent it will
depend on the location  of the Origin The
Original
Point ok so let me
this and What i have Here does not Tell
anything about the rate of convergence
unfortunately Mar theor powerful are no
General As far
conver
conver Mar and they
Silent Here this proof Here the proof of
this fact is  Dirty ok so
it it is not a General result but There
is also some intuition about this that i
can give you so how first do you con To
Say Zer or One
yes before We Which
one the fact that you the top and the
bottom absorbing set  M so what
prevents you from having a significant m
of jumping Back and forth in a limit
Cycle or something in the middle and
Never go to two absorbing
sets ok so Well Now if you Look at
Maybe my my answer Is The Following What
we are  really talking about Here is
really Strong
convergence there İsak convergence and
then strong
convergence so the convergence here is
strong
convergence ok so almost convergence
strong convergence Which does not allow
you to go Up and Down ETC
indefinitely ok so you have in Other
Words the
probability the  limit of
x
to x İnfinity equ
to not limit out in Here ok Something
like
this but There is has to do with the g
being the min of i of w and One min i of
w Right so if in the middle you polar
quickly the g  is very Large so it pushes
you towards the edges
his question The Following you know
ok What is your question You are
asking Why doesn't a significant
fraction of these later on Escape From
the boundary and accumulate near this
boundary they change roles in Other
Words a good fraction of this move
up you go Up and Down but Every Time you
Lose Something to the boundary and then
You Get an exponential Loss or something
eventually Lose Every
But but You don't Okay so let me also
Say The Following even with  processes
Mar that are not
bounded What you say doesn't happen it's
L ok so the number of Times you Cross
two boundaries like this is Never
infinite ok so if you Look
at a book on my recommendation for a
book on Mar is this Williams ok  he exps
It the first theorem
hees up Crossing inequality
up Crossing inequality
will
Wills ok i'm
sorry so this up Crossing inequality
tells you that you can do
ill if this you
and you know the ST Market Give many
chances to
do notle in Words it
does There
is
for
skip in the interest of
Time i would like to Give Rest of the
Talk Maybe 10 minutes or so explain how
encoding and decoding Take place and Why
they are low
complex so This is going to be example
of
encoding We have these Channel  We have
Done the calculations and these Numbers
Here are the capacities of the channels
that We have synthesized Okay so and We
would like to send data at a rate of One
Half so We are going to be encoding Four
of the inputs
Here We will be sending  One bit across
Four of them and then We Be freezing The
remaining Four so this One uh Has very
small capacitor We Freeze it we will
Freeze it input
ok so the bit Channel with the
smallest capacitor it gets İTS input
Frozen As Zero Let's Say and  then the
second smallest Capacity is this one
that two is Frozen The Third and the
fourth smallest they are Frozen so the
remaining ones one of them is very good
we will be sending data using it and We
be sending Four bits of data across
these ones that  one is
but you know That's All We can with
construction size the BL in these
Numbers are going to polar Of course and
Be The probability of is going to get
smaller
so specific Numbers so the Frozen bits
are Zer remaining
ones remaining ones are arbit
dat how  we doing is will it
stage by stage there are log and
stages Here logarithm of Capital
n so in for n equ to in three Time units
We have the encoded
cod so This is a Fly parel encoding
operation We are doing it par
Pr if you do  it sequentially How many
Operations some Operations are you doing
You are doing
log Clear that the encoding complex isog
This is
Basic
computing
transform transform using f trans
Method Simple
enough ok Here is the
example in three stages We Do the
encoding decoding is more interesting
the suggested  Method for doing decoding
is successive cancellation decoding i
haven't mentioned it until Now but these
cod have What's called the plot
structure u u Plus V or a a+
B in The Following Sense Here There is
an a Vector and There is a b Vector Here
and The  X Vector Here is Has this form x
equ to a and a+
B so these ches have very Close
relationships with read mod ches read
Mother codes also have this
structure and in decoding We Take
Advantage of
struct We have a a+ b structure not this
layer but  each layer you also have it
the B1 through B4 Here also Has this
sort of structure it is the Sum of this
Vector and this
One so it is recursively plot in Other
Words all the way
through so now in decoding
is
raos and they are available Now  the
decoding circ is going to work from
Right to left encoding left to Right The
Way i have drawn it it will be Right to
left The Following recursive
algorithm decoding Task for this
available
ATS they will be combined to compute
likelihood for B1 B2 B3 B4  so these are going
to be treated As noise these are
dat Back There is a Vector Here a Vector
is coming from some data and Maybe from
some Frozen bits We don't know what
these
are if some of these bits are
Frozen We know a little  bit about these
We know Something but in this decoding
We Don't try to take Advantage of our
knowledge of any of Frozen bits in this
segment
ok
so We Treat All of them asure
noise if noise is being
ising if We have anys about the We
wouldn't be able to do anything but
fortunately y5 tells Us Something about
A1 y6 about A2 and so On and in fact if
these are Perfect channels you know
these exactly We don't have perf but We
know Something about
so
B
Here of X1  and
X5 We know Something about both X1
and
decoding Task has been
reduced the present decoding Task is the
decoding of this segment
Which Original decoding
Task
Es
lik
to After i estimate these
ones We Make hard
decisions
decisions so We have likelihood relating
to these
ones using these lik We compute
lik
the
and isel ofil  u Plus V structure Here
andel rao is computed for
u1 and Now u1 if it is if it
is a Frozen bit regardless of What we
compute We it to the corre
value if it is a dat
then
map into Unique decision relating to B1
through B4 and  then Weed To The Next
stage of
decoding so these are Now hard decisions
these Things are to be estimated Now
if
Correct each of
CH w
Plus equ chn for A1 is a w Plus
Channel if these Things have been if B1
has been estimated
correctly w Plus but  w Plus this layer
Of
course i here
More uh detailed explanation of What we
are doing ok so This is the equivalent
Channel model so what you have Here Yes
indeed the w minus Channel ok so if you
Look at Just that Part of the Graph This
is  What you see so and then you have
this copy The Third copy and the fourth
copy They Don't interact with each
other ok so you have Four
copies and
wuse y and
YS B input to w Channel and you compute
the log rao for B1 to0  or One and you do
it for all of these and then you go on
to Now use B1 B2 B3 B4 andu Plus V
structure
here ra w1 and
w2 so Now w1 and w2 are effectively
being sent
over w minus
minus Yes
As ra
how Well it  is a they are not getting
Large i mean We Do this using four five
bits of precision in the Logic
domain Finally you have this One the
decision about u is made effectively
using this Channel and All the Channel
outputs ok so This is the log likelihood
ratio  uh if the log lik ratio you
computed Well if the bit is Frozen you
ignore this ok and you never Make use of
it if the bit is not Frozen then You
decide in accordance with the comped
ra computing
this u but Now We are to assuming that
This is Correct so We have this
structure Here We compute the L ratio
And it Goes On like that Okay so This is
an algorithm Whose complex n log As Well
and the Mar convergence theorem with the
rate of convergence Together with the
Union b
n for any rate  R Less than the Channel
Capacity there are three types of
complex in order to Call
Something Capacity with L complex
construction
ising and is
construction How is it to
Find the proper positions for the Frozen
bits ok so that is a result that Came
out of a succession  of Work starting
with mor
tanaka T and
vard and
Last
Jo
and He is not here i
but He proved Beyond that This is a
polynomial Time algorithm this ok in A
paper with several authors this result
was proven R
Peters and Other
People Don't remember  the exact names
so you have
aod for Which the construction
complexity is almost Linear encoding and
decoding complexity are n log and there
are no big constants in front of
these they are basically n log ok so and
then the frame Eror probability Go Down
exponentially
con
performance
Now perform and these are the result
here is du to T and these are results
that i have presented before they in 201
at
isit
inet
list of size One Which is the successive
cancellation decoding algorithm that i
have mentioned This is What you get in
terms  of
performance if you use a list decoder
with list size
two i won have Time To explain exactly
What this means but
essentially the L the weakness of The
successive cancellation Deer is that if
make a
mistake Pr to mistakes if
agn those chn Get polarized sufficiently
if  you use them You are Pr to making an
error there That's the weakness of the
successive cancellation decoding
algorithm so How do you Take care of it
the le decoding İdea i should also
mention the name
of because He Came up with this L in the
context of
the İdea İs The
Following you so you Follow both
possibilities You don't commit Yourself
to either Zer or One but you Follow both
possibilities This is important
especially at the
decisions B to
unreliable Channel that you are using
has not sufficiently polarized you want
to Still  use them otherwise you Lose too
much
from so if you use a list two decoder
there are many variations so the details
are not so important so essentially you
Keep Following Two branches and then
Keep the best two all the way through to
the end and at the  Select the better of
the two You Get a significant
performance improvement Here list of gives
further improvement
82 and in fact When You Get to L size 32
or so You are at the ml limit ok The
Reason Why this thing saturates Here or
settles Down to some  floor This is not
an error floor but It's a floor is
because Can
it
because
Ard and TS main good News was you know
not the L size doesn't really have to
get astronic Large to achieve the ml
Bound ok so with a reasonable list size
You Get Down to the ml
Bound question Here actually We see for
starting from
R8 like if you go Back to previous
Slide Yes Here the result You are
showing is for 8.5 Right Yes and so
recently Start working on mostly lpc
before and the complexity is Still  much
More complex compared to the ldpc like
not the in terms of the more in terms
GES but We are very interested in terms
of the seeing Where We are in terms of
the so We Looking both
ok let's discuss this After because
i'm a  Hur to Finish so that We Don't
Hold people here i will Finish in
minutes i Promise so this this thing is
due to theor minimum distance of the
polar cod ok so The Reason Why uh it
Hits this sort of error flor Let's Call
it error  flor because the minimum
distance grows only Square Root of n
When i saying only you know it's much
better than ldpc codes Which
aggressively try to achieve Capacity
because there the minimum distance goes
to a finite number ok
so This is going to Keep Going Down like
that  Okay but it Goes Down uh with the
Square Root in the exponent so How can
you Fix this the answer is you need to
improve the minimum distance of the C to
improve this so again T and they
suggested using a crc a concatenation
basically the crc is  going to Help
improve the minimum distance and When
You improve The minimum distance list
decoders with 16 bit
crc it achieves As good performance if
not better than turb
and ldb that are Used in ymax ok so this
One is the list decoder performance This
is list Plus  crc 16 performance and
these are performances of uh Turbo and
ldpc codes that are Used in
ymax Okay so There is Of course a lot
More work that has been Done Since then
on practical Side of these codes in
summary this is the summary ok so We not
only have a of ach limit but
also if We them with some Other methods
they have The potential To Be
useful so Thank you for your attention
and if you are interested in this
presentation and some Other notes you
can write to me or i will Leave this
Here so you May perhaps be able to copy
it As Well Thank you very much Thank
you very much Thank you
any
question explain theus of the
subal
ok so the The Reason Why
uh
it's ok so That's not i Said it's
intuitive but It's not so easy  in fact i
mean
if log of process not this One but the
log of this One it behaves As a Random
ok Which either stays Where it is or
moves Down One step so Half of
thees Stay where
are Point towards the boundary ok so
That's the main
Reason so basically This is a process
with
two two attractors you define let Say a
process like this ok Now it Has only one
limit Point Zero ok and then you Take
the Logar of this
One This process is approximately
process which
or
Zer with probability Half with
Probability
Half so This is the Basic intuition so
convergence to Zer in this Case it means
What does it me it means going to minus
Infinity ok so a process like this can
go to minus
Infinity of
step m
the rate at to minus Infinity
is
for construction  size of Capital n you
Take small n steps Logar of n steps Half
of log
n This is the number of steps only Half
of these steps are useful steps for
convergence the remaining ones
where you are ok so That's the
in ok
Right so We succeeded oh  yes That exp it
can't go faster
than ro is any other
than exps That it cannot Go faster than
2 to the minus Root n the fact that it
does Go 2 to the min Root n so the proof
using squaring of the prim there some
intu
that so i must also Say The Following
these Things are True for the for binary
binary Channel so if you go to larger
alphabet sizes uh the exponent there
improves and in fact the rate of
conver with increasing alphabet
size
Large alabet sizes it becomes is it
Clear What i have
Said
You both of
fact
know kern of size by iface this with
larger kerns using the using the binary
alphabet As this thing gets larger and
larger i mean it's kind of obvious that
you can Stick in Here anything you want
essentially you know  you you May have a
very powerful cod in Here As your kernel
yeah then the exponent here is going to
go to is going to improve to n
of binary
cally that
originate they
did they
Show exponent Call
exponent
si you can look it up they Show that
exponent improves to
around ok instead of Square ro n We are
Now talking about this number n
0. both avenes are Open in Other words
however you know Things Get More complex
so Here if you go to alphabets You must
be doing this sort of essentially bel
propagation on an alphabet ok if you use
this
structure by two
Matrix even if you Keep increase even if
you increase the alphabet size you
cannot do any Better Than This This is
what are referring to so this kernel
here
Alp Beta Gam Here for LG Field size  but
not
performance You Will have Square Root of
n if you for binary alphabets Let Me Say
this and then i will
stop if you restrict The alphabet To
binary and You look at larger and larger
kernels
kada Urban they
have
Things are not going to get any  better
until the size of this F the kernel
becomes larger than 32 ok so that Simply
Says That it is not
practical for binary Case for binary
alphabet We are using this two by two
kernel unless you go to of
size does not
worse Thank you very
much